hello YouTube chest lowers my friends
this is goon Chen here
welcome to the twelfth episode of dirty
chest tricks in this episode I am going
to show you an amazing gambit against a
particular English opening setup the
classical English opening start with the
moves c4 and against this I'm going to
recommend a reverse grand prix attack
set of which continue with the mordor
ePHI Knight to c3 Knight to c6 g3 and
the trademark mu F Phi which is favored
by none other than mr. Bobby Fischer
himself the usual line continues with
the move Bishop to G to Knight to f6 and
here white has a few choices if you
opponent plays the move d3 then I
strongly recommend that you play the
move Bishop to b4 and learn the grand
prix attack theory which is available
free in many books and Internet videos
similarly if you open and place the Moon
Knight at this point then this is a very
bad move the simple reason is that can
simply reply with the movie for not only
giving more space on the kingside but
white pcs are not ideally placed so
considering all the scenario the best
move over here is to play the move III
so idea is very simple white wants to
play the move Knight to e2 and then at
the right time he wants to hit back in
the center with the move d4 but so far
if you look at White's
opening this all three moves for example
c4 pawn c3 Knight and g2 Bishop all are
controlling the critical d5 square and
still white is going to play this
amazing stunner
that is defy it's just like indirectly
saying to the white sorry buddy defy is
mine now if you open and see this
move first time he will literally think
are you kidding me this is not possible
but in fact this is possible now
obviously White has three good choices
but I'll demonstrate in this video that
against all of this reply black obtained
of winning H so let's start with the
worst one first the first more I want to
consider is Bishop captures D file well
after this the usual response start with
the move Knight to b4 so there are two
main threats the first is to capturing
the bishop but the second one which is
the most potent one that is black is
trying to misplace white King with the
move Knight to d3 check now if you open
and foolishly played the move Bishop to
g2 oh here then after Queen to d3 at
least black can get an exchange in this
line so that is not possible so that
means White has to deal with this Knight
to d3 check there are two ways white can
defend this threat the first obvious
movies play the move d4 which is a
typical mistake done by many players in
this line because now black and played
the movie for so that night is going to
cement on d3 but that's not the only
thing black has a very sneaky threat so
for example if white plays any moves
let's say Queen to b3 in this game then
after the move c6 that Bishop is a goner
so that means d4 is also not possible so
that leads to the only move left that is
d3 but after this black is going to play
the move c6 anyways now the best move
here is for white is to play the move a3
against this I'm recommending that you
should capture the bishop and after pawn
captures and Knight captures yes the
material is balanced but white will
clearly feel the absence of the light
square bishop around his King as you can
see this light squares are become
severely
and not only that black has a bishop
pair and tremendous space in the center
so this is more than a sufficient
advantage that is a three but I like to
show you one of my very amazing game in
this line where my opponent played the
move Bishop to g2 so you seriously do
not want to give this LightSquared
bishop well following lines are very
forceful and it is fun to play as a
black black obviously kick start with
the move Knight to d3 check King to have
fun now Bishop to e6 threatening c4 my
opponent responded here with the move b3
now another threat with Bishop to b4 my
opponent responded here with the move
Bishop to d2 now another threat Knight
to g4 see the beauty about this line
every point black is developing his
piece with a threat and all white is
doing is defending here my opponent
obviously need to deal with the f2 so he
played the Moon Knight to b3 and now
comes boom and you should always watch
out for this sort of things well why
doesn't have any option white has to
capture this Knight and now the whole
idea reveals after the move Bishop to c3
it is very obvious that white cannot
capture this bishop because at the end
after Knight - III check white will lose
a queen so my opponent has to forcefully
capture this Knight and after this I
kept to the rook in the corner and then
there are few exchanges happen my
opponent captured the bishop I captured
his Bishop he captured my ePHI pawn and
pinning the bishop I captured his Knight
he captured my bishop and after King to
d8 Queen captures d4 after the whole
transaction you can see black emerged
with a exchanger we should see this game
because it's quite entertaining I
continue my attack with the move rook to
f8 check my opponent responded with the
move Bishop to f3 and I played the Mook
to f7 saving my G
pawn my opponent trying to rescue his
king so he played the MU King to g1 I
played the move King to c7
so my idea is to double the loop on the
F file and now he played the mu H for
indeed I double my rook on the F file
and now I'd plays the move Bishop to g2
so for a moment it looks like White has
consolidated his position and he can
look forward for the complications
well not that's not true I give you a
few minutes over here can you find a
more order which can finish up the white
okay I hope you find this mu that is
wrote to F in check so that leads to the
force reply that is King to s 2 and now
yep Queen captures g2 amazing stuff
first reply King G to rook to f2 check
King s 3 and the final finishing blow
Rope catches H 1 with an amazing weight
so this sort of fun you can get if you
open and try to save a special so with
this analysis we can easily conclude
that Bishop captures V Phi is not
possible at this position so let's look
at the another option that is what
happens if you operand capture with the
night so night cap is defined now here I
recommend that you should capture this
night and if you open in place Bishop
captures D Phi so there will be a
transposition of the lines which we have
already look at it so the critical move
is C captures D Phi well after this once
again black will play the move Knight to
b4 and creating two threats that is
capturing the pawn and putting the
knight on to d3 now here I need to
consider two replies if your opponent
plays the move d4 then once again this
is a typical mistake black will continue
with the movie 4 and in order to save
the knight d3 check black has to play
the move Bishop to f1 so this is almost
a moral victory because every single
piece of white is hit the back rank and
now we
are simply going to capture the defy
form once again I like to show you one
of my own quick win and this line here
my opponent responded with the movie
three I give this check anyways he
obviously captured my night and after
pawn recapture the first threat is
created that is capturing the rook now
obviously by doesn't want to play the
move f3 and weakening his King side so
he decided to play the move Knight to f3
I continue with the move Bishop to d7
and now he Castle on the Kings side
which is a big big mistake the simple
reason is black and play over here
Bishop to c6 not only hitting the knight
but that night cannot move because there
is a maid threat on this two squares so
it's a funny enough that just in few
moves of the opening white is obtaining
a losing position the only move left is
efore over here which is a very tricky
move that if black foolishly captured
with the Queen then rook to e1 and white
is winning but I didn't fall for that
I played the stronger move that is f
captures e4 now my opponents idea is to
play the move Knight to e5 and grabbing
that dangerous bishop I continue with
the move Bishop to d6 and after Knight
captures pawn captures he played the
move Bishop to e3 and after I Castle on
the Kings side we don't need to even go
further with this game he can easily
conclude over here that is black is
quite quite better look at those monster
pawns in the white camp all white is
going to do in this game is defending
defending and defending now the second
obvious move is to play the move d3 so
stopping any Knight to d3 intrusion well
against this I am recommending another
sharp gambit in this line with start
with the MU c6 it is quite surprising
that this line contains amazing
resources
and this is one of them now two moves
needs to be considered the first obvious
move is a three so immediately trying to
get rid of that night well against this
black has a super reply that is Queen to
a5 now if you're opening players over
here move such as Bishop to d2 then the
very simple replies a knight to d3 check
and let's say King goes anywhere for
example in this game I place the Mook
into e2 then after Queen to a6 Vitus in
the losing position not to mention if
the King tried to escape from the f3
square then after fo check King to e2
Knight to f4 double discover check and
after King to even and nightcaps g2 it's
actually a checkmate
so Bishop to d2 is not possible so that
leads to the only reply left that is
white capture this dangerous knowledge
and after Queen captures rook capture
this c6 pawn for a moment it looks like
white has a dangerous threat but see
yourself here that will continue with
this move Bishop to b4 check white
responded with the move Bishop to d2 and
after Bishop captures and keen captures
the following line will give you great
advantage here black will continue with
the move Queen to if I check and after
King to e2 I recommend that black should
play the e for so completely shut down
that Bishop I raise this position in one
of my game here my opponent responded
with the move D captures efore so we
seriously want to open up that line and
create a counter i simply reply with the
move be capture c6 and now he played the
move he captures f5 which at first side
looks very natural because it's hitting
the c6 but the end is near
I played the move Bishop to e6 check and
and this is just a horrible mood to meet
unsuspecting my threat my opponent
carelessly played the MU King to f3
but after Queen to fi this is actually a
checkmate so you can see the games can
down very very quickly for the right now
instead of a three right can also play
the move D capture c6 well against this
the response is pretty much force black
has to play the move Knight captures d3
check and after the move King to have
fun we should play the movie 4 so we are
completely shutting down that Bishop the
critical line is Queen to e4 so trying
to get some discovery check well this is
not good the simple reason is black can
capture this pawn and after Queen
captures black and responds with the
move Bishop to d7 so not only black is
developing is all pieces but White King
is clearly misplaced and to illustrate
how dangerous this position is I like to
show you one quick game where black
demolish white very very quickly
so here white responded with the move
Queen to e6 black responded with the
move rook to be it so there is a threat
of Bishop to b5 which white stuff with
the move f4 but now black creates the
another threat that is Queen to c7
grabbing the bishop so I responded with
the move Bishop to d2 now black plays
the move rook captures B to see how
amazingly black initiative is
development with every move black is
creating her threats again white is
forced to play the move Bishop to even
now another strong move Bishop to b4 so
idea is to capturing the bishop and then
delivering a checkmate on f2 so white
stop everything with the move Knight to
e2 but after the following sequence that
is Bishop captures Bishop rook captures
well you can see if black ones can
easily get that rope but black find a
stronger continuation that is
rook captures e - BAM and it's just time
to pack in the simple reason is if white
captures this rook with the king then
after Queen check came to have fun and
queen catches f2 as a checkmate so these
are some of the wonderful tricks in
Knight captures default line now the
final and the most critical mu I want to
consider is C captures D Phi but against
this our reply is pretty much same we
are going to play the move Knight to b4
so creating a two threats and now White
has two options either to go d4 or d3
White has also tried the move Queen to
b3 but that will lead through a
transposition into the d5 variation
which we are about to see so against the
move d4 as usual we are continuing with
the movie 4 and now white plays the move
Queen to b3 so with this more white is
saying that okay I am ready to accept
that my king is going to miss place but
on other hand I'll put my PCs on the
active squares do you Lu state the
danger in this position I like to show
you my own game where I continue with
the move Knight to d3 check my opponent
responded with the move king to have fun
and now I played the move Bishop to d6
so it is very important that to block
this d5 pawn with your piece
my opponent continued here with the move
Knight to e3
I played the Moon Knight to g4 and now
he played Knight to be fine so he
clearly want to get rid of my bishop and
then post his knight on there Foursquare
well actually I allow him to do this
with the move castle on the Kings side
he delighted to capture my bishop and
after I capture with my queen he played
the move f3 which was his whole idea so
destroying my pawn chain and same time
hitting the night but when you play this
sort of move you should always
look out for the surprises and that's
actually I delivered to him can you
sports black next move it is a night
catches s2 boom
more or less white is forced to obliged
to accept this sacrifice rook captures
s2 and now Queen captures g3 so double
threat
checkmate threat on even as well as
capturing the rook the only reply is
king to g1 and now this game will
demonstrate that combination of Knight
and queen can be sometimes very very
little so here I continue with the Moon
Knight - even the threat is Knight
captures f3 so my opponent first of all
give me this discover check with the
move d6 and after King to h8 now he
played the move King to edge no matter
black get his piece back after the move
Knight captures g2 please note white
cannot capture this night because Queen
Ken captures on h3 so the game continues
here with the move f captures efore and
I think here I played the best move of
the game that is night twitch 4 which
has a well simple idea Queen to even
check so my opponent has to deal with
this threat and he played the move
Bishop to d2 but the game is ended right
there can you spot it yup is Knight to
f3 and it's amazing that just from this
2 piece I created a havoc in the white
cam white can just resign over here the
simple reason is there are two checkmate
threats exist which white cannot defend
both of them so that was about the moody
for your opponent can also try the mood
d3 over here but against this I'm
recommending that you should capture
this defy pond and after Knight captures
and Knight captures I like to show you
the danger in this position the general
response is to play the a3 so stopping
any knight or Bishop intrusion well here
I
a very simple plan starting with the
move c6 so now the idea is very simple
what black wants to do is to play the
move Bishop to d6 Bishop to e6 Queen to
e7 and castle on the Kings side but the
simple moves not only black can finish
its development very easily but because
black has a tremendous space in the
center these positions are quite
favorable to the black as usual I like
to show you one good trick and the slide
one of my very strong opponent here
responded with the move Knight to e2 I
continue as per our plan so I played the
move Bishop to d6 he castle on the King
side and I did the same and now he
played the move Queen to b3 so you can
see the easy idea is it's attacking two
spots that is d4 and b7 well against
this we have this amazing gambit
starting with the move work to epsilon
and just like him many of your opponent
are going to be tempted to capture this
defy night because simply white can beam
upon yup that's true but afterwards the
initiative black develop is tremendous
there are great chances that game can
finish very very quickly after this move
to illustrate this I like to show you
this game which highlights the power of
the black development here I continue
with the move Queen to e7 so try it is
Bishop to b6 he completed his piece
development with the move Bishop to d2 I
played the move Bishop to b6 and now he
played Queen to b4 I gain more time to
the screen with the move a 6 and B 5 and
finally Queen safely placed at d1 square
so for a moment it doesn't look like
black has any compensation and white
emerged with a clear upon up but now the
fun start with the MU f4 it is very
logical that black wants to open up this
position because it has a bishop pair
and tremendous pistol of mine
and my opponent immediately get rounds
over here so he get annoyed by that pawn
so he captured with the I pawn and now I
played the move Bishop to h3 hitting the
rock and this is what happened as soon
as you see that Bishop to h3 move
without much of consideration my
opponent played the move rook to e1 but
he soon realized that after my next move
the game is finished can you spot it yep
is Queen to b7 and there is no way white
can stop Queen - G - checkmate 1 mu has
been played f3 and after Queen captures
e2 the only option left is to shake the
hands so I hope with this amazing gambit
you can get many quick wins against the
English opening well thank you for
watching this video and I'll meet you in
my next lecture
bye